i love pound cake
this is my favorite part it is about to
blow your mind hey everybody it's your
girl mikko food blogger over at mikko in
the dish and i gotta put it out there i
love pound cake there are very few
recipes as quintessential to southern
baking as pound cake the issue is
sometimes it comes out either too dry or
too dense so today i'm going to show you
my foolproof tips and tricks for making
the perfect rich buttery pound cake with
a citrus glaze you ready
let's go
in my stand mixer i'm going to add some
butter next i'm going to add some sugar
so you might be thinking this looks like
a lot of butter and sugar but actually
the original pound cake was made with a
pound of every ingredient so this is
actually on par with the way the
original pound cake was made i'm going
to cream these ingredients on low for
about three to four minutes and that's
what's going to give the cake to
scariness
all right
that looks good now i'm just going to
scrape down all of the edges next i'm
going to add my eggs one at a time just
to make sure that they fully incorporate
and just a little tip for you guys make
sure that you crack your egg on a flat
surface that way none of the shells go
into the egg
there you go you almost escaped buddy
now i'm going to scrape this down once
more just to get all those ingredients
to the center and then i'm going to add
some sour cream and that's going to give
the cake a little moisture and some tang
next goes in my vanilla
and i happen to love a little citrus
flavor in my pancakes i'm going to add
some orange extract
that orange vanilla just smells so good
so all my ingredients look great
everything is nice and creamy the
perfect texture so my wet ingredients
are done now it's time to get my dry
together
over a large bowl i'm going to add my
flour and my salt and i'm going to put
it through a sift it's going to make
sure that all of the clumps are broken
up now it's time to add our dry
ingredients to our wet but make sure
that you add them one cup at a time this
is going to ensure that all of the flour
gets incorporated evenly and that you
don't overwork the batter the reason why
you don't want to overwork your batter
is because that's going to produce a
really dense cake and that is not going
to get you invited back to the potluck
all right so i've gotten to the bottom
of my bowl let's add that to our batter
[Music]
all right
the batter looks and smells fantastic
but there's one more important step that
we have to do before we put it in the
oven
i'm using a butt pan to make my pound
cake my grandma use a bun pan i'm using
a bun pan you can use whatever you want
as long as it holds 14 and a half cups
now the thing to remember is you want to
make sure that your pan is prepared so
that the cake doesn't stick i'm spraying
my pan with cooking spray and i'm being
generous with it you want to make sure
you get that spray in every crevice of
the pan i'm going to lightly sprinkle my
pan with flour and i like to rotate to
make sure that the entire pan is evenly
coated next i pat as i rotate to make
sure that the flour distributes across
the pan
all right this looks evenly coated now
i'm going to add in my batter this looks
really silky and smooth and we're not
adding my batter i just like to add it
around the bunk pan in a circle
to make sure that we get it evenly
distributed
a lot of air made it into my batter when
i pour it into my pan so a good trick to
get rid of that excess air is to give it
a shake and to drop it
you only need to do that a couple of
times and then it's ready to bake i have
my oven set to 300 degrees i'm gonna
throw this in there for an hour and a
half
[Music]
while my pound cake is in the oven i'm
going to show you how to make a citrus
glaze now i'm going with citrus because
it's in season during the winter in a
large bowl i'm going to combine my
powdered sugar my milk
melted butter
vanilla extract
the zest of a lemon some lime zest and
finally i'm going to zest my orange and
yes this is an orange even though it
looks yellow let's mix it all up until
it's well combined
this glaze looks perfect all i have to
do now is wait for my cake to be done
our cake has been out of the oven for 10
minutes cooling off now it's time to
flip and release it
okay guys now's the time of truth
oh
it's beautiful completely clean okay you
guys see that
it looks incredible
now we're gonna let it cool for another
30 minutes before we add our glaze
oh
this is my favorite part adding that
glaze
i cannot wait to try a bite
ah
look at that oh my goodness
this cake is so
delicious the outside kind of forms this
crust that's nice and sugary and then
the inside of the cake is moist and
buttery and decadent and then that
citrus glaze just up
it is so good and when you guys try this
cake it is about to blow your mind
all right guys so today i showed you how
to make the ultimate pound cake with a
citrus glaze i'm really interested to
hear what you think about this pound
cake leave a comment down below or hit
me up on instagram at mikko in the dish
until next time peace
oh yes
do
you